good evening
i wanted to give you an update on the
current situation in afghanistan
as you know we were set to leave
afghanistan this month and as we began
the final drawdown
i made some critical errors
namely
i underestimated the strength of the
taliban
and i overestimated the strength and
capability
of the friendly afghan forces
this was my fault
and due to my mistake
the taliban has taken control of
afghanistan
there are reports now that isis and al
qaeda
are working alongside them
unfortunately there are tens of
thousands of americans on the ground
there
as well as friends and allies of america
on the ground
and these people
americans and our allies are all
stranded
and that is my fault
but they will not be stranded for long
in the next 48 hours
america will be in control of most major
airports in afghanistan
any resistance we meet
from the taliban or otherwise when we
seize these airports we'll be destroyed
completely and without mercy
from those airports we will conduct
rapid strike rescue missions until we
have recovered and evacuated all our
citizens allies and friends
any person that interferes with these
operations will be killed
we will also
recover or destroy
all aircraft vehicles weapons and
sensitive equipment that we left behind
any person utilizing guarding or located
in close proximity to these weapons or
equipment will be killed
once we have evacuated all friendly
personnel
and recovered or destroyed the weapons
and equipment left behind we will depart
afghanistan
but
we will continue to monitor
everything that happens in afghanistan
through our ground and airborne
surveillance equipment
terrorist training camps or activity
will be targeted and destroyed
gross violations of human rights
will be stopped through overwhelming
force
and any group in afghanistan
fighting for freedom
liberty
and basic human rights will be supported
through special operations forces
and ruthless precision air power
we will continue that dedicated support
until the enemy is no longer a threat to
humanity or
to the good people of afghanistan
may god bless america
and may god have mercy on the souls of
our enemy because we will not
that is all